[Musique]
le président du département et
l'ensemble des élus se sont réunis ce
mercredi 18 novembre en commission
permanente
l'occasion de revenir sur les incendie
du maïdo survenu la semaine dernière le
président rapplique le travail
partenarial et collectif avait permis de
prendre des décisions rapides et
efficaces contrôle a été le veiller à ce
que le a conseillé aux 10 mètres des
lignes de défense pour que le feu ne
déborde pas de la planèze et ne rentre
pas dans les tamarins ou là on part sur
des feux de route des feux souterrains
le feu de muscler son très difficile à
contrôler et un deuxième mais ni la
disposition de moyens humains de l'onef
à travers une équipe de bûcherons qui a
été mis à la disposition de façon
permanente depuis le samedi pour
permettre d'ouvrir des lignes dans la
végétation pour permettre aux pompiers
de détendre leurs lignes lors ligne de
lens et puis de mettre en place
d'élargir à 5 m une piste vtt qui avait
été conçu pour faire une deuxième ligne
de défense au cas où le ferait déborder
le département a voté un plan d'action
post incendie compte tenu des dégâts à
identifier et des problématiques qui s'y
rattachent le 110 du maïdo nous sommes
sur une phase qui est peut-être la plus
longue au niveau d'un incendie que nous
avons déjà rabattu toutes les flammes et
nous sommes en train de traiter toutes
les lisières de façon à ce qu'il n'y ait
plus du tout de propagation vers
l'extérieur de la partie qui est non
brûlés il s'agit tout simplement de
creuser tout autour du feu une petite
rigole qui sera inondée donc rempli
d'eau et qui permettra à l'eau de
rentrer en profondeur et d'éviter toute
provocation par le sous sol
sachant qu'en surface les flammes ont
été abattus et il n'y a pas de
propagation particulière par les flammes
ont les habitants de mafate
effectivement la remontée vers le maïdo
va être compliqué étant donné les
risques de déstabilisation qui a eu
partie de la végétation qui retenaient
les blocs a été brûlé donc ça ça veut
dire qu'il ya des blocs qui sont près
stabilisée qui sont qui secoue de se
remplir retenue donc là c'est plutôt le
nf et le brgm qui vont faire le qui vont
faire le travail de diagnostic de toute
façon il faudra attendre les premières
pluies pouvoir comment comment les
choses bougent comment les choses se se
rééquilibre ou pas et à partir de là des
décisions sont prises mais effectivement
l'axé maïdo rouge pas de maillot ça va
être un petit peu un petit peu compliqué
dans les mois qui viennent ce plan
d'action porte sur trois points la
reconstitution des milieux naturels
dégradés l'ouverture du belvédère pour
l'accueil du public et le rétablissement
de l'accès aux sentiers de roches plates
pour désenclaver nul est
[Musique]